he's got a weird reputation of [ __ ]
over the people that he made made
Facebook with I don't know yes I don't
know if that's correct or not but that
movie man I'd sue the [ __ ] out of those
people made that movie if that's not
true right in the movie that kind of set
it up like he stole the idea well he had
to settle he settled out of court paid a
lot of millions to like the Winklevoss
brothers I think too too because they
said it was their idea yeah they made
him look like a dick in that movie
though yeah they sure did yeah it's kind
of heavy that that movie actually got
made you would think that they would
have got paid off to not make it well
it's weird to make a movie about a
person it's it's even if they got
accurate reports from other people it's
so weird to make a movie about a person
who's still alive right now put words in
his mouth a lot of it's speculation too
no matter what for sure yeah well he got
a flight it says that the settlement was
20 million in cash and 45 million in
face book stock price they're worth
billions yeah yeah if he did dick them
over but who knows if they're telling
the truth yeah I don't know whose
version is always there's always two
sides every story but a movie about you
like if somebody made a movie about you
and you know had you on the beach saying
some [ __ ] you never really said you like
hey I didn't say those words you can't
have me say those words with an actor's
inflection and his decisions to make
whatever creative choices he makes with
the way he talks and 99% of the people
watching that movie aren't having this
conversation right people they just
automatically think that Zuckerberg
that's what happened yeah he's a dick
you know that he did those that's the
perception it's like if you uh if like
Jamie was like hey you know what I just
got fired by Jill [ __ ] that guy Jose Joe
Joe tried to touch me this one day when
I was shooting the techno for the target
he tried to touch me everyone maybe
believe Jaime as much if he was like a
really pretty girl
yeah well Jamie could be a pretty girl
free shaves hair goes he did try to stop
it being made Shin you would though I
just stopped the movie social network
for being made I was from those leaked
Sony emails that came out and that
hacking
of course he did but I think he has a
right to it honestly yeah here's the
thing pretty happy that someone can make
a movie about you without write your
consent and put words in your mouth
that's the thing maybe one thing if you
were convicted in a court of law right
for that stuff but if this is just like
yeah I swear this happened see here's
the thing though it's one thing there's
a documentary and in the documentary
they're showing footage where Zuckerberg
is doing certain things saying certain
things it's a total different situation
if you decide to put words in that guy's
mouth and you have [ __ ] Justin
Timberlake plam in a movie who played
him in the movie I think it was Justin
Timberlake was it Justin no he's in a
Newark Oh Jesse Eisenberg so you have a
famous actor the famous actor plays you
in a movie and makes you out to be a
[ __ ] that sucks
it's his choice he [ __ ] and then the
directors like make it a little more
kunti can you do a little more contine
like a little more of a dick I'll be a
little more removed here I'll try a
little more removing this next take yeah
it's like you can't do that like you
should you should be able to sue the
[ __ ] out of those people because at the
end of the day it's one thing to tell a
story hey I work with Zuckerberg that
guy was a dick he stole my ideas it's
another thing to have someone play him
in a movie yeah and make up a bunch of
words that he didn't really say or you
don't know he really said oh you don't
have any proof that he really said
that's [ __ ] strange he made it up